مدير cia يقول ان ايران قريبه من تخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 90% ويعلن ان الصين تدرس
تزويد روسيا بالسلاح
الاتحاد الاوروبي يفرض مزيد من العقوبات
على مجموعه فيغنر الروسيه ويتهمها بزعزعه
استقرار البلدان
ومحادثات اسرائيليه فلسطينيه في العقبه
بمشاركه امريكيه لتجنب تصاعد العنف
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الاهم الانباء من العربيه هكذا مدير
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه في
مقابله مع شبكه سي بي اس نيوز ان ايران
باتت قادره على تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه
90% خلال اسابيع لكنه قال انه لا يعتقد
بان المرشد الايراني اتخذ قرارا باستهداف
عسكره برنامج بلاده النووي وكذا في اللقاء
ذاته احتمال ان ترسل الصين مساعدات فتاكه
الى روسيا في حربها ضد اوكرانيا مضيفا ان
الصين تحاول تقييم العواقب في حال زودت
روسيا بالسلاح
فرض الاتحاد الاوروبيه عقوبات جديده على
مجموعه فاجنر روسيه لانتهاكها حقوق
الانسان في عدد من الدول الافريقيه وجاء
في بيان للمجلس الاوروبي ان العقوبات
الاخيره فرضت نظرا الى البعد الدولي
للمجموعه وخطوره نشاطاتها بالاضافه الى
تاثيرها المزعزع للاستقرار في البلدان
التي تنشط فيها
وكان قائد قوه
على بلده ياغدني شمال مدينه مخموت بعد
مواجهات مع القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت بعدها
باجنر من الوصول الى اخر نقاط السيطره
الاوكرانيه في باجني بطريقه وبطريقها الى
البوابه الشماليه من مخموت بما فاد مراسل
العربيه بان القوات الاوكرانيه فجرت احد
سدود نهر سفيرسكي دونتس لوقف تقدم باجنر
في بخموت بعد انسحابها من بلدات تابعه
للمدينه
ومع بدايه العام الثاني للحرب الروسيه
شهدت اوكرانيا عده تطورات فقد اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني عن 27 غاره جويه روسيه وخمسه
وسبعين هجوما من عده قاذفات صواريخ كما تم
الابلاغ عن اصابه خمسه مدنيين في مقاطعه
اما في منطقه خرسون الجنوبيه فقد ابلغت
سلطات الاوكرانيه عن 83 هجوما روسيا لما
صرحت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الجيش
الروسي قصف نقاط انتشار مؤقتا لوحدات
العمليات الخاصه الاوكرانيه ومشاه البحريه
في مقاطعه دينيبرو بتروبيسك واضافت ان
مجموعه القوات يوجني التابعه للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه قضت على اكثر من 120
عسكريا اوكرانيا ودمرت خمسه قطع من
المعدات من ضمنها طائرات عسكريه
قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان اوكرانيا قادره
على الانتصار هذا العام مضيفا ان المانيا
تساعد في حمايه الاوكرانيين مما وصفه
الارهاب روسيك
هل يمكن ان ننتصر نعم نحن قادرون على ذلك
في وحده وحزم وبلا هواده نحن قادرون على
وضع حد للعدوان الروسي هذا العام كانت
المانيا معنا منذ الدقائق الاولى من الغزو
الروسي المانيا تساعدنا في حمايه
الاوكرانيين من الارهاب الروسي وستكون
معنا في يوم الانتصار
ردود فعل دوليه متباينه بخصوص الاقتراح
الذي قدمته الصين للسلام في اوكرانيا كيف
رحبت ببعض البنود وروسيا اشترطت الحفاظ
على مناطق سيطرت عليها خلال الحرب اما
الولايات المتحده فشككت في الخطه قبل ان
يرفضها
خطه الصين للسلام في اوكرانيا بين التشكيك
والقبول والرفض موقف واشنطن بدا متململا
الخارجيه الاميركيه شككت في الخطه بدايه
قبل ان يخرج بايدن ويعلن رفضه لها صراحه
اذا كان بوتين يصفق لها فكيف يمكن ان تكون
جيده انا لا اريد ان اكون طريفا انا جاد
للغايه لم ارى شيئا في الخطه يشير الى
انها ستكون مفيده لاي احد اخر غير روسيا
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل الذي اعلن انه
سيزور الصين مطلع الشهر المقبل اكد ان
السلام ممكن واصفا جهود بيكنج بالامر
الجيد لافتا الى دورها في الضغط على روسيا
ياتي ذلك غداه نقل صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال
عن مصادر ان باريس ولندن ابلغتا الرئيس
الاوكراني
بضروره الاخذ بعين الاعتبار مفاوضات
السلام
زيلينسكي رحب ببعض عناصر المقترح الصيني
لوقف اطلاق النار لكنه قال ان الدوله التي
تدور فيها الحرب هي التي ينبغي ان تطلق
خطه السلام ان كانت هناك افكار تتوافق
بطريقه او باخرى مع احترام القانون الدولي
وسلامه الاراضي فلنعمل مع الصين في هذه
النقطه من جهتها قالت روسيا حليفه الصين
انها تقدر جهود لوضع حد للنزاع مع تشديدها
على ضروره الاعتراف بضم موس اربع مناطق
اوكرانيه تطالب بها
المندوب الروسي لدى مجلس الامن قال ايضا
ان وضع حد للاعمال القتاليه في اوكرانيا
سيسمح للعالم بالتعافي اما الامم المتحده
فقد اعتبرت خارطه السلام الصينيه بشان
اوكرانيا مساهمه مهمه
خطه الصين تحث كلا الجانبين على الاتفاق
على خفض تدريجي للتصعيد وتحذر من استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
بلال البجدين العربيه
قال نائب رئيس البرلماني الاوكراني في
مقابله خاصه للعربيه ان وثيقه السلام التي
اعلن عنها الرئيس زيلينسكي بسيطه وواضحه
تتضمن انسحاب روسيا من اراضينا بشكل كامل
وعوده حدودنا الى ما قبل العام 191
وثيقه السلام التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
زلينسكي اقرت في قمه مجموعه دول العشرين
نحن في اوكرانيا نرى انها قمه التسعه عشره
دوله لان روسيا لا تستحق ان تكون بينها
وثيقه السلام بسيطه وتستند الى مبادئ
واضحه مثلا انسحاب روسيا من اراضينا وعوده
قواتها الى موسكو من دون باس والقرم ايضا
وعوده حدودنا الى ما قبل
1991 موقف اوكرانيا واضح وقوي ويدعمه
الاوكرانيون نحن واضحون لا نريد اي تسويه
مع روسيا على حساب سيادتنا بعد كل ما
عانيناه من الحرب ومختلف الاسلحه التي
استخدمتها روسيا لتدمير بلدنا
من المقرر ان يستضيف الاردن اليوم اجتماعا
بين كبار المسؤولين الامنيين والسياسيين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين بمشاركه
الامريكيه في محاوله لوقف موجه العنف التي
اندلعت في الاونه الاخيره الاجتماع الذي
سيعقد ليوم واحد في بناء العقبه على البحر
الاحمر ويحضره
مبعوث الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في الشرق
الاوسط سيجمع للمره الاولى منذ عده سنوات
بين كبار قاده الامن الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين بالاضافه الى ممثلين عن
اطراف الرئيسيه في المنطقه
الاردني محاوله تهريب اسلحه وقنابل يدويه
بواسطه طائره مسيره ومفخخه قادمه من
الاراضي السوريه الطائره المسيره التي تم
اسقاطها داخل الاراضي الاردنيه كانت محمله
باربع قنابل يدويه وصلاح اوتوماتيكي وزميل
عماد العضايله كان في وقت سابق برفقه
الجيش الاردني على الواجهه العسكريه
الشرقيه على الحدود مع سوريا
[موسيقى]
ويشده الجانب السوري من انفلات امني وتغلل
لنفوذ الايرانيه وميليشيات حزب الله وجب
على الاردن تكثيف قبضته الامنيه على حدوده
مع سوريا نرصد برفقه الجيش اي حركه مشبوهه
من الجانب السوري من اقرب نقطه على الحد
الفاصل بين البلدين
عمليات تسلل ومحاولات لتهريب الاسلحه
والمخدرات تصل احيانا ل 13 عمليه في اليوم
الواحد ويصل عدد عناصر التهريب احيانا الى
200 شخص للعمليه الواحده
حقيقه ومع هذه الهجمات الشرسه بكمها
ونوعها واهدافها في اغراق العالم
بالمخدرات تغيرت قواعد الاشتباك اطلاق
النار على كل من يقترب من الحدود
وفيما تعد سوريا بؤره لتصنيع المخدرات
تعتبر محافظه درعا الجنوبيه مركز ثقل
لانتاج ماده الكبتاجون باشراف ايراني
وعناصر من حزب الله وتحت رعايه النظام
السوري ممثلا بالفرقه الرابعه نظام يسعى
بحسب مراقبين الى تصدير ازماته الداخليه
للخارج واستغلال نفوذه في ظل عوز وفقر
وجوع الشباب السوري
على الجانب الاخر من هذه الحدود تمتد
السيطره الميليشيات المواليه لايران داخل
سوريا بين محافظتي السويداء ودرعا
المتخمتين للحدود الاردنيه حيث تتزايد
عمليات التهريب الى الجار الجنوبي
الاردن اعلن عن احباط محاوله تهريب جديده
لكنها ليست كسابقاتها من حيث الاسلوب اذ
حاول القائمون على المحاوله تهريب اسلحه
بطائره مسيره مفخخه امر يعتبر سابقه لم
تشهدها المنطقه من قبل وفقا لمصادر في
الجيش الاردني الطائره تم اعدادها
بالطريقه المفخخه في حال تم ضبطها من قبل
عناصر حرس الحدود كانت تحمل بندقيه من
طراز انفورم واربع قنابل يدويه
تمتد الحدود بين الاردن وسوريا لمسافه 375
كم تحتوي على معبر اثنين هما معبر الرمثا
ومعبر جابر او معبر نصيب الاكثر حركه
وازدحام في داخل السوري تنتشر على طول هذه
الحدود ميليشيا حزب الله والفصائل
المواليه لايران تدير عمليه تهريب
المخدرات والاسلحه الى الجانب الاردني
بينما يتحمل الجيش الاردني حراسه وحمايه
الحدود من جانب
وفقا لمعلومات متقاطعه العام الماضي سجل
رقما قياسيا في عمليات التهريب وحجم
المواد المهربه حيث ضبط الاردن سته عشره
مليون حبه مخدره خلال خمسه واربعين يوما
فقط وهي كميه تعادل ما تم ضبطه خلال 2021
باكمله
عمليات تهريب المخدرات المنظمه اخذت
بالاستفحال عقب السيطره الميليشيات
الايرانيه على المنطقه الجنوبيه من سوريا
عام 2021 ليس الى الاردن فحسب بل الى كل
اسقاع الارض
ايضا تتابعون في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
في طهران احتجاجات الليليه عبر النوافذ
والشروفات تمديدا برموز النظام الايراني
اهلا بكم مجددا الى هذه النشره من العربيه
شهدت العاصمه الايرانيه احتجاجات في حيي
المانيا وتشيجر حيث علت الاسطح شعارات
مناهضه لرموز النظام من قبيل الموت
لخامنئي ولن يكون الوطن وطنا الا بدفن
الملك
[موسيقى]
جاهز
قبل ذلك اظهرت لقطات مصوره اعتداء وحشيا
لعدد من عناصر قوه الامن الايراني على رجل
في مدينه جاهدان وذلك في اطار حملات القمع
التي تشنها السلطات ضد المتظاهرين في مدن
اقليم
جنوب شرقي البلاد
[موسيقى]
تشابهت حكايه مقتل جبل رني على يد شرطه
الاخلاق الايرانيه شهر سبتمبر الماضي مع
مقتل الشاب البلوشي ابراهيم الذي توفي
داخل مخفر للشرطه جراء التعذيب وفق مصادر
اعلبيه ايرانيه في وقت حضر فيه اطراف داخل
ايران من موجه احتجاجات متجدده كتلك التي
حدثت عقب مقتل امير
تماما مثل ما حدث مع ماسه اميني السيناريو
نفسه يعاد لكن الضحيه هذه المره متظاهر من
اقليه البلوش يدعى ابراهيم ريقي
حينها تعددت الروايات بخصوص مقتل ماسه
اميني انكار ثم اقرار بوفاهها داخل قسم
الشرطه فصدور لتقرير النفع تعذيبها على يد
شرطه الاخلاق عكس الصور المسربه التي كشفت
تعرضها للضرب القصه تعاد بحبكه مطابقه
تماما مصادر اعلاميه ايرانيه قالت ان
الضحيه اعتقل من قبل الشرطه وتعرض للضرب
داخل المخفر قبل وفاته نتيجه الاصابات
قاضي شعبه القتل الخاصه والطبيب الشرعي
اكد وفاه ابراهيم ريقي بسبب الضرب الذي
تعرض له داخل مخفر الشرطه رقم 12 الشرطه
اعلنت ان الحادثه وقع خارج مخفرها لكن
مندوبي الطب الشرعي وبعد فحص الجثه
وملاحظتهم ان ملابس الضحيه ممزقه اكدوا
انه توفي نتيجه اعتداء وقع بعد نقله الى
المخفر
المنظمه العفو الدوليه اكدت من جانبها ان
هناك ادله تؤكد وفاته بسبب التعذيب اثناء
احتجازه من قبل الشرطه هي حكايه جديده
قديمه في قائمه تضم اسماء من تمت تصفيتهم
بسبب معارضتهم للنظام او فقط تجراوا على
الخروج للاحتجاج رجل الدين البلوشي عبد
الغفار نقشبندي حذر السلطات من عدم تعلم
الدرس ما لم يتم الكشف عن العناصر الامنيه
التي تسببت بمقتل ريجي منبها الى ان
العواقب ستكون مشابهه في اشاره للاحتجاجات
بلال الوجداني العربيه
اكد رئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن انه ينوي
اعلان ترشحه لولايه ثانيه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقرره في 20 24
لكنه لن يقدم على هذه الخطوه الان
يدوي ترشح لولايه ثانيه في انتخابات
الرئاسه 2004
الرئيس الامريكي لن يحدد متى سيقدم على
الترشح للرئاسه
ردا على سؤالنا جب بيضا بمسحه من البدايه
كانت الترشح لولايه فاكهه
يؤثر عمر الرئيس الامريكي على الترشح من
المشروع ان يثير الناس قضايا تتعلق بعمره
الفحوص الطبيه تدعم بايدن صحته جيده وقادر
على اداء واجباته
السيده الامريكيه الاولى
سبقته بحسم ترشحه
[موسيقى]
سيتم الاعلان عن ذلك
مع بعض من الضحك والسخريه اكد رئيس
الامريكي جبيد نيته الترشح لولايه ثانيه
وهو امر اتبعه الرؤساء الامريكيون
واحزابهم في التاريخ المعاصر
يبدو ان احدهم سال زوجتي عن ترشحه وعلي ان
اتصل بها واسالها الحقيقه ان نيه دائما ان
اترشح لكن علي ان انهي امورا عديده قبل ان
ابدا الحمله الانتخابيه نفهم من كلام
الرئيس الامريكي ان حوضه الانتخابات
المقبله مؤكد لكن اطلاق الحمله الانتخابيه
رهن باعمال الرئاسه وفي مقدمتها الاقتصاد
وحرب اوكرانيا
انا لا اتصور بان الرئيس بايدن هو خطير
على الحزب الجمهوري لانه السياسه التي
يقوم بها واداره الرئيس بايدن بالفعل
بالنسبه للوضع الداخلي هو وضع اقتصادي
ينهار يوما بعد يوم والتضخم المالي لم
يستطيعوا حتى الان لتوقيف هذا التضخم
المالي الحاصل وثانيا بالنسبه للسياسه
الخارجيه هناك وجه اخر لترشح بيضا عن
الديمقراطيين فشعبيه نائبه الرئيس كمال
هاريس ليست عاليه وربما تخسر الانتخابات
امام الرئيس السابق والمرشح الجمهوري
دونالد ترامب فالناخبون يفضلون الجمهوريين
لكن من المرجح ان ينتصر بيضا على ترامب
بنسبه 3% فيما تخسر هرس امام الرئيس
السابق بنسبه 5%
ما زالت الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
تقوم على سؤال اساسي وهو فوز او خساره
ترامب فهكذا كانت في الدولتين السابقتين
وهي هكذا الان ربما الرئيس ترامب ضعفت
شعبيته منذ سنتين ولكن اليوم نشعر بان
شعبيته تزداد يوما بعد يوم لانه بالمصائب
التي تضرب الولايات المتحده السياسه
الداخليه والخارجيه واداره الرئيس بايدن
لم تتعاطى معها
بالواجب حسب قدره الولايات المتحده ربما
نشهد في الانتخابات المقبله اعاده لمشهد
العام 2020 جزء اساسي من ذلك هو المنافس
الشخصيه بين الرئيس الحالي
والرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في الغنم
العربيه واشنطن
ظهر مقطع فيديو بطل العالم السابق في
الوزن الثقيل للملاكمه وشقيق عمده كييف
وهو يقود دبابه المانيه صنع التي ستظلمته
اوكرانيا مؤخرا
لم افكر مطلقا انني ساقود هذه عام من
الحرب في اوكرانيا عام من المعاناه وعام
جديد ايضا من تعزيز قوه ارادتنا اكثر من
اي وقت مضى اراده قويه شكرا المانيا على
هذه الدبابه شكرا للعالم على كل ما
يفعلونه لنا ايها الاوكرانيون المجد
لاوكرانيا المجد للابطال
من مواصله الدعم السياسي والعسكري الغربي
لاستقبالي رسائل فنانين ورياضيين عالميين
هكذا بدا الحال بالنسبه للاوكرانيين مع
ذكرى مرور عام على اندلاع الحرب مع روسيا
منصه تدعى يونايتد 24 بثه فيديو تضمن
رسائل مشاهير من هوليود ورياضيين داعمين
للاوكرانيين في هذه الازمه
دعم اوكرانيا الغربي ينتقل الى عالم
الفنز
نحو 30 نجما يوجهون رساله دعم للاوكرانيين
من خلال منصه لجمع تبرعات اعاده بناء
اوكرانيا
منصه يونايتد 254 بثت فيديو الدعم في ذكرى
مرور عام على الحرب من بين هؤلاء ماديمون
الحب والتضامن مع جميع اخواننا في
اوكرانيا
تعددت الرسائل ومحتوى التضامن واحد من
بينها رساله جوليا روبرت
نفكر فيكم ونرسل اليكم الحب ونرسل لكم
قوتنا ودعواتنا ونبقيكم دائما في قلوبنا
وغيرهما من فنانين ومثقفين ورياضيين
[موسيقى]
مشاركه واسعه وشكر من الرئيس الاوكراني
على رسائل الدعم
علي السمان العربيه
سلطات في كوريا الشماليه افلام ما هوليود
في البلاد وتوعدت اولياء الامور بعواقب
قاسيه في حال سمحوا لاطفالهم بمشاهدته
ممنوعه في كوريا الشماليه بامر من كم
اولياء الامور في كوريا الشماليه تلقوا
تحذيرا من عواقب قاسيه
العواقب تشمل ارسال والد الطفل الى معسكر
عمل لسته اشهر
سلطات
طالبت الاهالي بتثقيف ابنائهم وفق المثل
الاشتراكيه واذا لم يقم الاباء بتعليم
اطفالهم فسوف يرقصون ويغنون عن الراسماليه
ويصبحون معادين للاشتراكيه
قرار منع افلام هوليود سبقه قرار تغيير
اسماء الفتيات اللائي يحملن اسم ابنتي
فالختام هذا تمكير لابرز العرب
مدير يقول النيران قريبه من تقسيم
اليورانيوم بنسبه 90% ويعلن ان الصين تدرس
تزويد روسيا بالسلاح
الاتحاد الاوروبي يفرض مزيدا من العقوبات
على مجموعه باجنار ويتهمها بزعزعه استقرار
البلدان
ومحادثات اسرائيليه فلسطينيه في العقبه في
الاردن بمشاركه امريكيه لتجنب تصاعد العنف
دائما لمتابعه ملفات العربيه والمزيد من
الاخبار والتحليلات على موقعنا العربيه
دوت نت رجاء مسح الكود الظاهر على الشاشه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]